[Music]
today we're gonna be joined by Peter
Baucom Peter is the platform lead at
Quizlet and the two of us are going to
be talking about running open source
databases on Google cloud platform so a
few goals for today we'll take a look at
what we view as some of the most popular
open source database databases in the
market right now and we'll look at how
you go about running those databases on
Google cloud platform we'll take a look
at what Google offers what some of our
partners offered with respect to managed
services and we'll look at how you can
self manage these databases and then
Peter will join on stage and he'll talk
about lessons learned by Quizlet with
respect to running my sequel on Google
cloud cloud platform Quizlet generally
has as a really impressive my sequel
architecture and I know I'm excited that
he's here to share some of their
learnings through through I think some
some pain and some certainly some
success as well running my sequel on
Google cloud platform so before I jump
in let me just ask a question to all of
you by show of hands how many developers
do we have in the audience okay so about
today a little more than half the room
maybe even 2/3
how many database administrators do we
have in the room a few how many
Reluctant database administrators do we
have in the room there's a few more and
how many managers do we have in the room
we got a handful ok great well I hope
that the presentation will have
something for everyone and heed I think
it will so let's get started here we'll
take a look at popular databases and
we're going to start with the analyst
view of the world this is a an analyst
view of the database market as measured
by by revenue by market share the bars
you see on this slide are not to scale
you if you look leftmost we have our our
database market at just over 35 billion
dollars and we compare that to the open
source database market and the no sequel
markets at 300 and change million so if
we actually represented those at scale
or in relative scale those would be like
a pixel and you wouldn't be able to pick
up the numbers there
the take on this at least from my
perspective is that the analysts are
measuring a market in a very rational
way they're looking at dollars spent or
money spent on databases usually in the
form of database licenses and also in
support contracts and associated
services historically this is very much
benefitted commercial databases that
often come with large license fees
I think the reports like this tend to
understate the significance of
open-source databases in business and
this is starting to change now this view
of the world is starting to change in
that cloud vendors like Google some of
our partners other cloud vendors are
offering database services based on open
source databases and they're finding
significant interest from customers and
that's generating revenue so these bars
are starting to change over time I
honestly think what we have here is kind
of a a massive shadow market where if
you surveyed everyone running an
open-source database you've got a very
large number of users depending
day-to-day on open source databases and
it's not reflected in these type of
reports yet okay with that in mind we're
talking about the the smaller segments
on this chart are open source database
charts we Google have a very casual
relationship with with the company
called DB engines DB engines looks at
signals things like job postings
development activity at a number of
other signals to determine how popular
relatively our databases one to another
what we're showing here is a list of
databases you can see rightmost column
we've highlighted databases relational
databases like my sequel and Postgres
for example along with Maria DB we've
highlighted some of the the no sequel
databases [ __ ] and and new sequel
databases Cassandra Redis a lot to
search HBase and what you see is kind of
a relative popularity note that the
y-axis here is in log scale so you have
my sequel at the top kind of the most
popular open-source database at least as
measured by database engines and you see
some others that are growing in
popularity over time now given the log
scale you've got something starting down
on the y-axis at two
while my sequel is above 1000 so bear
that in mind but we've seen in the
relational space very steady growth in
terms of popularity for for a database
engine like PostgreSQL and you can see a
number of the others that I've
highlighted here growing in popularity
over time what we'll look at as we go
forward are these databases what options
Google has for you with respect to these
databases in Google cloud what options
our partners bring in terms of managed
services and how you can get started
self managing one of these databases and
what I'll note here is as a product
manager for cloud sequel which is a
managed database service I certainly
have a bias I love manage database serve
services but I think what it comes down
to in terms of selecting do I self
manage a database do I go to a managed
database service is really the trade-off
between customization and that time and
toil and management when I think about
looking at a database service versus
self managing I think you all are aware
of the trade-offs you're making
day-to-day with your time as developers
as DBAs as managers you are deciding I'm
going to customize this part of my
technology stack and I'm willing to
spend the time to maintain that part of
it of the stack other parts of the stack
you may say I'd like to turn this over
to someone else and in doing so I'm
gonna get I'm gonna give up some of the
customization I can get by managing it
myself I think that's the trade-off you
look at so as we go through these
options hopefully they simply illuminate
some of the options you have with
respect to these databases on Google
cloud and then Peter will join on stage
and Peter will take you through their
rationale quizlets rationale for self
managing my sequel and some of the
experiences they've had on Google cloud
platform so let's start with my sequel
and marija DB which some will call my
sequel clone certainly a fork of my
sequel for the Google offered service
here cloud sequel or manage relational
database service has for years offered
my sequel cloud sequel we say is
compatibility but more than
compatibility we are more than just a
compatibility layer I should say we are
offering standard my sequel databases
and cloud sequel takes care of often
mundane and maintenance operations
things like patching the database patch
the underlying operating system making
replication feel easier click button
we monitor high availability for example
and your backed by Google's team with
respect to high availability so it goes
beyond just the tooling to make sure
that a database is up and if it's not
that we're failing over you're getting
someone in the end looking at these
systems 24 by 7 so that you don't have
to that's that's kind of the essence of
the manage database service what I will
note about cloud sequel is that it is
not a DBA the hope with cloud sequel is
that for developers it offers you a
chance to develop to focus more on your
development rather than on database
management for DBAs I hope it allows
DBAs who choose to use cloud sequel a
chance to do something a bit more higher
value with their time than installing or
provisioning a database or patching a
database for example we have a partner
in clear DB offering managed services in
this very space as well and we have we
note in our launcher platform which is
pre-built images or OS images that
include an installation of my sequel or
for Kona or other relational my sequel
relational databases we have those
options for you so as you kind of move
down this chart you'll see this again
and again as I go through these we have
Google's managed service a partner's
managed service and options for you to
quickly get started as self hosting
these databases taking a look at
Postgres cloud sequel as of yesterday at
this conference announced support for
the first time for PostgreSQL it was a
long-standing request and we're very
happy to be saying yes to that request
now so cloud sequel for Postgres just
went beta as of yesterday is launching
right now we have elephant DB who is
running a managed service as a partner
and you see in the launcher space here
offerings from enterprise d be a strong
Postgres partner from Aven who is
offering a managed service as well
and we have bit Namie images which
effectively package a Postgres
installation into an image so you can
quickly get started with Postgres one
thing to note on the DB engines ranking
here you see the rise in Postgres over
time I think the momentum behind
Postgres right now is really exciting it
has a long history of active development
and we're excited as Google now to have
an offering in the manage
here taking a look at Cassandra and
HBase Google has a product called
BigTable which I hope you've all heard
of it has an HBase API layer so when we
talk about HBase at Google we refer to
BigTable as kind of our product in this
space in terms of managed service
offerings our partner instance into the
cluster excuse me has offerings around
this Cassandra space and then of course
we have launcher images both Cassandra
proper as well as from data stacks to
help get you started with Cassandra and
you can see kind of some interesting
movement in in the Cassandra and HBase
rankings in the DB engines chart to the
right
looking at MongoDB cloud data stores are
offering in this space data stores is
often paired with App Engine for those
of you who are familiar with it but
datastore is is great when it comes to
big scale especially document storage
looking at managed service offerings
[ __ ] Labs has an offering as well as
compose in MongoDB in the launcher space
again we have a standard [ __ ] options
and MongoDB with replication to help you
get going rapidly with MongoDB on the
Google cloud platform and looking now at
Redis we've recently unveiled App Engine
memcache
I think you will continue to see us
innovate in this space we think
in-memory databases are important in
caching later is important there the
managed service offerings we have our
via partnerships with Redis labs and
again with Aven and we've got some
representation from Aven I think in the
audience potentially today as well
looking at our launcher space we've got
classic Redis as one of our launcher
applications if you haven't been the
cloud launcher take a look we see
customers getting some value out of
launcher even if just for things simple
things like testing and then those
images things can certainly end up in
production but it's just a quick way to
get started with some of these
applications on Google cloud so I'm very
happy to now be introducing Peter Baucom
from Quizlet Peters the platform lead
and Quizlet is a heavy user of my sequel
and generally a heavy user of the Google
cloud platform so Peter I think has a
great story to tell and hopefully some
lessons learned that you can all benefit
from with respects to running my sequel
on Google cloud platform
so please join me in welcoming Peter
thanks everybody
I'm Peter I work on platform at Quizlet
and I'm really excited to be here today
I think to preface this you know there's
an implication if I'm standing up here
that we have we've solved all these
problems and we have this perfect great
infrastructure so it never goes down and
I I definitely don't feel that way but I
think the value and these talks is just
for us to give you information about how
we run our infrastructure and hopefully
my goal is you'll come away from this
with just a few more ideas and some
context and what we do and hopefully
that would help you if you're running
something similar so that's my goal here
I'm gonna give you a bunch of
information about our architecture some
decisions we've made how we configure
things etc and hopefully it'll be useful
and there's gonna be questions at the
end if you don't get your question and
I'll be around as well just to chat
about it if you're interested in doing
that so I'd like to start with just a
brief introduction to Quizlet if you
haven't heard of us Quizlet is an IDI
tech company we make a study tool that
you plug your content into and then it
helps you practice and master that
content so we've had really strong
adoption in high schools colleges things
like that it's really good for a
vocabulary foreign language etc we have
a web and mobile native apps and some
stats on us we have about 25 million
users a month and on Quantcast were like
a top 25 us web site so we've grown from
something pretty small into something
that's having a major impact on
education so this has been our growth
curve over time so we're really lucky to
have strong organic growth but the
things I want to point out here is this
is a challenging domain to run databases
in so you can see we're an education
company it's very very seasonal so no
one studies over the summer it turns out
it's pretty quiet so we get this big
drop-off in the summer and then every
year in August September we hit back to
school when US students returned high
schools universities and we get this big
jump
that's also where a growth hits so
summer is you know we really focus on
load testing preparing for that rush and
effectively we are preparing for a level
of traffic that we've never really seen
so this is difficult we get these big
seasonal swings of traffic and we need
to we need to manage and and deal with
this it's really important that we stay
up and stable if we go down this is what
happens this is a tweet of a classroom
all the students are holding iPads that
say Quizlet is down on them and actually
the projector in the back says that as
well and so I I put this up here just to
empathize with the user a little bit and
underline like why we feel this is
important to us and why we care about
like running this really staple e and
performant ly and avoiding this kind of
situation which is hard it's hard to see
when this happens right so that's that's
why we're here like many applications
Quizlet started pretty simple it was our
founder Andrew wrote it to help from
self study in high school and when we
started it was pretty simple it's just
an application in a database written in
PHP communicating with my sequel and as
we've grown as we've hit that growth
curve over the past ten years we've had
to scale this up we've had to react
attacked and solve this this scaling
challenge so what have we done so this
may be a pretty familiar list to to a
lot of you you know we've done the basic
stuff we've added indexes we've
optimized our queries we've done things
like eliminating joins so our queries
almost always hit a single table we've
moved to bigger Hardware so we've just
scaled up vertically and we started
caching query results I'm going to talk
a little bit how we use memcached we've
moved to partition tables so we've taken
a single table and we've used my sequel
partitioning to split that into multiple
individual files on disk we've
compressed table data
this helps with disk i/o and
probably our biggest scaling effort has
been around taking tables and splitting
them out into their own hardware so this
is just vertical sharding so our biggest
tables we run on separate instances once
you do this you have a more complex
architecture but you get much much more
scale we've also because we use
replication we've started running
queries on on replicas sets so these are
the queries that don't necessarily need
to be exactly consistent so if you do a
right you need a read they don't
necessarily need to be completely
up-to-date but this is a really nice
scaling strategy and once you do this
you can then increase the number of
replicas and scale this way so this has
been our strategy as I said I'm sure
that some of you are probably familiar
with this and have done similar things
and I want to talk a little bit about
kind of the implications of this on our
architecture and what this actually
looks like to run on GCP so here's our
current architecture this is just a very
high-level diagram we have the web app
it's talking to these pods of master
replicas pairs we run the replicas so
that we can swap between when we need to
do maintenance or if there's a
production issue on the master we're
able to failover and promote the
replicas to a master and and run that
way the important part is the replica is
always there it's always ready if we
need to swap over we run a separate
replicas for backups and we snapshot
this replicas and I'll explain a little
more about that as I mentioned before
we've taken tables and we split them
under their own hardware so we've ended
up with we now we're in a production
eight of these like pods of master
replicas pairs and in some of these pods
like in the middle here we run multiple
replicas so we've scaled in that way and
then finally we run this tier of caching
and this is the the application
communicates with this pool of mem cache
machines and this alleviates some of the
load on my sequel I'll talk a little
more about that so what does our
workload look like
as I mentioned we've we've split out
into separate pods we have about three
terabytes of production data and if you
add in the indexes that's another 2.2
terabytes
so I think of this as kind of a
medium-sized workload there's many my
single workloads that are much much
larger than this but this is basically
the the domain we've scaled into during
an average week we peak around 28,000
queries per second and that's kind of
spread across all of our databases
across all of the replicas and in total
we have about 40 billion rows and that's
across 100 tables so you know whenever
we had a feature or something like that
we often end up with an additional table
and so the app is communicating with
about hundred tables in total so this is
the shape of the workload and you know
we're there's a bunch of entities in
there that 40 billion rows it's both the
content so the Quizlet our content is
term and definition pairs that's what
people were studying but it's also some
more analytical things so we record
every answer that anyone punches into
Quizlet and we can use this to help
people study later on so this is
important data and it's important that
it's in the production database rather
than just an analytical database so we
can use in the application and help
drive studying later on so this is our
traffic during an average week I think
this is pretty common with a lot of
consumer facing companies but this is
starting Saturday so you can see not
much studying on Saturday Sunday night
we start seeing this hump and then
during the week we see a bunch of
traffic in the morning this is when
people are using Quizlet in school in
the classroom and then we see another
hump at night and so this is when people
are studying at night for the next day
so you'll notice that we don't see that
evening hump on on Friday night so I
think one question that I would have is
so why why are you guys doing this why
aren't you running cloud sequel it's the
managed service it would solve a lot of
these problems so my philosophy on this
is you should use manage services
whenever and wherever you can and they
have a huge huge potential to save you
time save you money save your
operational cost etc
we moved over to the GCP a couple years
ago and at the time we needed larger
machines than cloud sequel offered and
we've kind of continued to scale up to
larger machines and so we're now running
on on 64 core VMs we'd also had
operational experience running my sequel
on our previous cloud and so we had a
relationship with Percona and we've
tuned our databases specifically for our
workload with percona
so some of the configuration was was
specific to us and we wanted to continue
having control over those we also had
experience managing the replication and
failover and we like to control that
because we know you know where you are
in the recovery step and what the
replication is doing and being able to
handle that kind of promotion and that
kind of thing
you know there's a maintenance cost
there and complexity cost but we want to
be able to handle that ourselves but as
I said we're very very optimistic about
hosted infrastructure and we use it
wherever we can and will likely revisit
how we run this stuff over time so how
have we configured this what does this
look like so we run Percona my sequel 5
7 this is a recent Prachanda release and
as I said we've we've we run a different
bunch of different machine sizes so the
smaller machines the backup machines are
eight core they're the standard eights
and this scales up to 64 core machines
so we're using the high m64 cords which
are about 400 gigs of memory and those
those are where we need the most power
and we have the biggest database
workloads we're using the Google just
vanilla PD SSD drive so this is 25,000
high ops and so we've optimized our
workload around kind of that ceiling in
that number and it's it's important to
us we're also using GT ID based
replication so the thing to know about
that if you're not familiar with that GT
id replication is a way of tracking the
transactions that have been sent to a
replica and then executed on a replica
and they're important because if you
have two databases that have the same GT
ID executions then you can be pretty
sure that they have the same database
state so it's a really convenient way of
managing this
and when we're swapping in replicas we
ensure that there's GT ID consistency
there so I just wanted to call that out
as an important piece of this we've done
a number we've done a number of things
to tune the workload and the things that
I want to highlight there are the
biggest configuration changes we've made
from a performance standpoint have been
to tune in the buffer pool sizes and
optimize this and tune the number of
buffer pools so ruffle pools as you may
know it's how my sequel is caching pages
in memory so it's an it's a my sequel
manage cache and we tune this to be
around 80 percent of the memory on these
machines when you're running genes with
a number of cores so 64 cores you're
gonna end up with a number of worker
threads and the buffer pools are a
shared resource and so if you don't
scale the number of buffer pools with
the number of CPU cores you end up with
contention so we found it very important
for our performance to optimize the
number of buffer pool instances and the
current number we use is two - CPU cores
- a buffer pool instance though we may
experiment more with that so next I want
to talk about how we access this from
the app so what does it look like on the
ground when the Quizlet app actually
talks to my sequel so Quizlet was
originally written in PHP it's
originally just a PHP my sequel
application I think a lot of apps start
this way PHP is not the favorite
language of many people and so what
we've done is tried to optimize how we
use it and prove how we use it and the
the state we're in now is we're using
hhv m which is facebook's PHP
just-in-time compiler it carries a
number of advantages we were able to
significantly reduce our machine
footprint we cut our number of web
servers by about half by switching to HH
vm and it also introduces a layer of
type information so if you're just
running vanilla PHP HH VM attempts to
detect the types you're using and
optimize based on that we've also begun
using a language called hack which is
based on HH VM
and here's number of features but at its
simplest it's it's like a typed PHP so
we've transitioned a lot of our code
into hack and this has had a lot of
benefits and the application developers
are pretty happy about this so
application running in hh3m we're
communicating with my sequel via h h vm
p do which is an extension written in
c++ that you know handles details of
connections queries etc and communicates
directly with my sequel so all of our
queries are going through h h PM p dl
finally moving a layer up we're running
a custom all around so within our
application this big h h vm application
queries are going through this o RM as
you can see I've included a sample query
at the bottom here this is a fluent
interface we have for composing queries
you can do things like add query
predicates filters etc you can mark a
query as read scalable which means it's
okay to send to the replicas and it
doesn't need consistency and then this
is going to handle the actual composing
the sequel query and sending the results
back so this is how we're actually
forming the query communicating back to
the application this is what this is
what our developers are interacting with
so I want to talk about caching for a
second
this I think is an interesting piece of
this puzzle because the caching caching
gets a little tricky I want to explain
why we run a fool of them cash machines
I think this is a pretty standard
architecture we do consistent hashing so
each node each web node is can
communicating with each of the memcache
nodes and we're hashing consistently so
each key from all the web nodes ends up
on the same memcache node so we're
basically utilizing them cached as a
cache for my sequel the advantage here
is we reduce the query load so we're
sending fewer queries to my sequel but
we're also because we're storing this in
cash we are freeing up a lot of the my
sequel cache for other queries so things
that would have been going in the buffer
pool increasing buffer pool turnover etc
or instead just going to memcached
so this is great but this gets tricky
remember there's really only one source
of truth for our data so my sequel is
the source of truth for a data it's our
the whole thing rests on my sequel it's
our transactional relational database
and fundamentally if we do a transaction
if it fails to write to memcached the
transaction still succeeds but memcache
is out of sync so this is particularly
important because we're using memcache
as a model cache so literally our models
in my sequel are models in the
application we're serializing those and
we're storing those in in memcache and
so when those get out of sync you can
see you know you immediately have app
you have inconsistency in the
application so we mitigate this
partially by setting a TTL on everything
we write to memcache so effectively when
this happens there's a limit on the
inconsistency you could see but it's
important to keep this in mind there's
the possibility of inconsistency for
example if there's a network disruption
you'd see this and certain things you
don't want on this framework so for
example queries around billing right you
don't want that to happen it's really
really critical so you know we we
utilize caching I think pragmatically we
think it it's really beneficial to
reduce the load on my sequel but it's
really important to keep keep this in
mind when we're using it and we think
we've played around a lot with this
about you know where do we set the TTL
where do we bust the cache etc there's
another way of complexity here that if
you rebalance the cache buckets and then
you rebalance again you also have the
chance of stale data so we've spent
we've we've spent a lot of time thinking
about this about how we managed the cash
pool and you know just the sender to be
thoughtful and avoid this situation what
I'm getting at is is basically if an
memcache no drops what do you do you
know one perspective maybe you REBOUND
you REBOUND store cache but if this is
flapping you can end up with a lot of
stale data so we actually never
rebalance the cat
we use it so next I want to talk about
our database failover infrastructure
what I mean by this is is we frequently
need to failover from a master to a
replica and for both the replicas to the
new master this is tricky because
fundamentally you need to ensure data
consistency and you want to do this
while you're running the application you
want to reduce downtime you want to
reduce the problems you're seeing so
here's here's how we handle this we're
doing service discovery with console and
the way this works is console console
holds the master and the replica holds
the IPS and then we're templating files
from console so this means we're able to
change the value in console and then
this this templates the value into
config files on all of our application
servers and this happens really really
quickly so that's how we we do the
service discovery but the application
still needs to be aware of which is the
master when and we need to ensure that
there's consistency when we do this
failover
this is a little bit tricky so here's
our process for this we kick off we kick
off this process we pick a replica we
know we want to swap over to this
replica we run as the master and the
first step is to snapshot that replica
so this will come in useful later on
when we restart replication so we
snapshot the replicas we then lock
rights on this whole system so on the
database we're switching we stop doing
rights and this is because we need to
wait for the replicas to catch up we
need to wait for the failover so we lock
rights this is this is critical because
this has a major impact on the app the
database that you're doing this failover
on your then effectively not serving
that to users so this is a major input
impact on how the application is running
so we walk rights and then we wait for
the replication to catch up on the the
new master we're waiting in practice our
replicas are often within a second of
the
the master in terms of of transactions
but we want to be really extra sure that
they're caught up because if you don't
wait for replication to catch up you're
effectively leaving rights behind when
you swap to the new master so we wait
for replication to come up we promote
the replica to the new master
so this is where console comes in this
is where we change the service discovery
we're templating the files on all the
app on all the application servers and
then they know that ok this is now the
master we then unlock this database so
this is kind of the point of no return
right this means we are both writing to
the new master and reading from it and
so this is the phone of no return
because you then can't go back to the
previous master without losing rights so
this is a critical piece of this so
we've unlocked the application comes
back we're reading and writing and then
the next step we need to do is to
restart replication the other way so in
other words the old master now needs to
replicate from the new master this isn't
strictly necessary but what we do to
avoid replication problems is that we
then restore the snapshot from the old
replicas put that on the on the new
replicas so we ensure this complete
consistency the GT IDs match exactly
and then we restart replication so now
we're running we're running fine we're
running smoothly we're back in action
this actually gets even more complex
with multi replica pools so as you can
imagine you then need to pick one of the
replicas to failover to and any other
replicas then need to be aware of this
process and point to the new one so as I
mentioned before there's a lot of
complexity in managing this we have
experience with this and we have you
know you have scripting around this but
the complexity the scripting is
difficult to test because to test it
really thoroughly you need a very robust
staging or integration testing
environment and yeah so I did the point
at the point I'd like to make is just
that there's complexity we manage it
because we like control of it we like
knowing exactly the characteristics of
when the failover is happening and being
able to fix it if something
something breaks but there's no there's
cost to it so next I want to talk about
something that's super important to us
as backups so we're replicating data to
another replica which is smaller and the
purpose of this machine is just to keep
up with the right load and keep a state
with the master so in other words follow
closely behind the master we're not
reading from this note at all this is
one of my favorite parts of GCP this is
one of the things we liked most when we
have our we were evaluating GCP as as a
potential platform the GCP snapshots are
very very quick
so even multi terabyte SSD drives we can
snapshot those like literally in a
matter of minutes this is pretty
significant because what it means is you
can get a full copy of a disk consistent
it's really really quick and it's fast
enough that we're able to do this once
an hour so if we were to lose the
running instances we have the most data
that we would lose in that scenario is
an hour's worth of data this is pretty
nice we just we press the snapshot
button it goes it saves and we have this
guarantee so there's some other things
we want to do in this infrastructure so
one is we want to test these backups we
want to make sure that they're
consistent they're saying if we need
them we can we can bring them back in
and we also want to store some some
copies of this elsewhere so we want to
store copies in the event that we would
lose access to GCE what if we lost
access to entire GCP accounts etc we
want to solve that problem as well so
this is what our architecture looks like
as I mentioned we have this backup
replica this has an SSD that we're
snapshotting and then we do a couple
things with this with this drive we take
the snapshot we turn into a disk and
then we mount it on to other machines so
first as a backup tester all this
machine does is it looks for an untested
backup it brings it in it mounts the
drive and it does the my sequel recovery
so once the my sequel recovery is done
you can run queries on this and we just
run pretty simple queries so we're
making sure that
is like saying the tables are as large
as we expect we're seeing recent
timestamps on the tables etc the
worst-case scenario here is you try to
do a backup and you realize your backups
are broken we do test things to ensure
you don't see that right we also have an
archiver and what this is doing is it's
mounting the drive it star balling up
just the raw binary my sequel files and
then it's shipping those off into cloud
storage so we're shipping it's a GCS and
then we're also shipping it to s3 to
ensure we have a backup that's just
outside of our GCP account domain so you
know this is important to us because we
want to make sure that if there's a
disaster we can recover our backups are
saying coherence we have copies
elsewhere etc so we've we've put some
time and thought into this I also want
to talk about data warehousing so we
this is great we've we've solved backups
we've solver up we've solved replication
and failover etc but our data analysts
they want this data my sequel is not
there's a class of queries that that my
sequel is really not intended for right
analytical queries queries over your
entire data set large scans etc so you
know at the scale we're talking about of
a database of several terabytes there's
a lot of queries that a scan over the
entire database is going to take hours
right so we use bigquery as our data
warehouse we really like bigquery and we
push both production data so the my
sequel data into bigquery but also event
data we're streaming there and so to
join these two datasets we need to do
this we need to do this copy so how do
we do this this is a diagram of this
process basically we've written a go
clients and all this client does is it's
it's executed on micron it's scanning
through the entire backup machine and
it's streaming this into a GCS file so
what we end up with is a group of files
sitting in GCS I believe they're JSON
format and this is an entire copy of our
database once it's in GCS it becomes
easy right you press a button and
you're able to import it into bigquery
and bigquery actually handles the the
table swapping of in other words we have
a new copy of the data we're putting it
on bigquery and then we need to swap it
in for the old table so bigquery is
handling that for us so remember this is
a totally separate system and this is
executing on a cron so this is not up to
date up to the minute it depends on the
table size but we run this for some
tables every day and for some tables
every week so there's separate systems
and there is a delay there but it's a
big win because you're then able to
process the my sequel data in bigquery
and you're able to join that against our
event data which was also sitting in
bigquery so we really like this we
really like this architecture we were
like bigquery and it's been really
powerful for us so as I mentioned
there's this kind of unfinished and
there's a lot of improvements we're
always iterating on this and I just kind
of want to call out something that you
know we internally at Quizlet think
about and and want to improve so one is
we want to improve our scripting around
failover there's a lot of complexity
here but quicker failover is better
there are a few things that we want to
do to to increase the speed with which
we can we can do this and the other
thing that we see is the recovery
sometimes involves manual steps
so if replication is off if the GT IDs
are off etc we've seen cases like that
that sometimes involves the developer
actually going and looking at those and
those we'd like to narrow down on and
eliminate another thing that we see is
the larger GC as GCE instances live
migration is not totally transparent for
systems that are running really really
heavy transactions and the effect of
this is effectively your your machine
just kind of drops for a second so
you'll see you'll see a little basically
be a live migration blackout the machine
will disappear for a few seconds then
it'll come back so this is pretty tricky
you don't you want to be able to trust
the VM
we mitigate this by we watch for these
so we there's a notifier you can watch
they'll told you when the live migration
is coming but fundamentally you need to
be you need to avoid single points of
failure and you want to avoid relying
too much on a single machine as I said
the the bigger machines are more
susceptible to this so the smaller
machines you can run the better in a lot
of cases a big problem with our
architecture is we haven't Torre's on
totally scaled yet so we're not doing
sharding of a single table across
multiple databases and we've done this
basically to be pragmatic there's huge
amount of complexity that comes with
with managing sharding yourself there's
a lot of solutions in this in this space
as well and effectively we've been able
to punt this problem and shard
vertically rather than horizontally but
a river represents a pretty fundamental
limitation on this architecture but one
of the things we're looking at is is
what other technology we can leverage as
you saw we have a really strong growth
rate and so our architecture is going to
continue to change and we're going to
have to adapt to the requests from users
coming in so we've been experimenting
with cloud spanner as as a replacement
for my sequel in certain in certain
places and an option for continuing to
scale this up and so actually we did a
talk yesterday about what we learned
about cloud spanner as a replacement for
some of this architecture and we have a
blog post about this as well so it's
also targeted at kind of if you're
running a my sequel architecture and you
are figuring out what the next step of
that looks like its intended for you so
that's what I have I hope this was
useful and helpful and I think we're
gonna take questions but if you don't
get your question I'll be around as well
and happy to chat more about this stuff
[Music]
[Music]